The Daily Show is marking the end of an
era host Trevor Noah signed off at the
late night comedy show last night after
surprising his fans in September with
the news that he would leave Noah had
led the program since 2015 when longtime
host Jon Stewart stepped down The Daily
Show airs on Comedy Central which like
CBS is owned by Paramount Global as CBS
Saturday morning co-host Michelle Miller
reports Noah's exit is part of a larger
shift in late night TV
it was a night of tributes for Daily
Show host Trevor Noah the whole time
here it felt like it was just the two of
us immigrants just coming together to
tell
Americans what was wrong with them which
they always appreciate
as his correspondence and celebrities
took turns sending him off with a bit of
quitting a job in America you're about
to lose your health insurance you should
probably sign up for cobra
whose heavy dose of common
so term poignant with Noah reflecting on
his seven years and the state of
American democracy and polarization
somebody that you may not agree with on
most things can do something that you
like
and taking an emotional few minutes to
thank those who had shaped him you truly
want to know what to do or how to do it
or maybe the best way or the most the
most Equitable way
talk to black women they are they're a
lot of the reasons that I'm here
September 28 2015. when Noah first took
over The Daily Show from his wildly
popular predecessor Jon Stewart his very
first joke highlighted just how far he
had come I'm not gonna lie growing up in
the dusty streets of South Africa I
never dreamed that I would one day have
well two things really
um and indoor toilets
and and a job as host of The Daily Show
I sat down with him in 2016 for CBS
Sunday Morning he talked about his
childhood during apartheid his first
year hosting the Daily Show and the
mixed reaction to his appointment when
The Daily Show came out and said Trevor
Noah our new host America was like who
it was
you know my favorite thing it was like
America was like who and then there was
like a subset of people in America many
of them immigrants many of them people
who had family overseas and they were
like finally
Matthew bellany is a founding partner of
Puck a digital media company this is
still an overwhelmingly white male
profession but Trevor Noah at least
looked different and had different
thoughts and perspectives
though Noah initially struggled to
attract an audience his show eventually
grew in popularity particularly on
social media but TV viewership has
continued to decline following 58 since
the start of the
2016-2017 broadcast year and The Daily
Show isn't an isolated case the leading
network shows have all seen double-digit
decreases prompting concern over the
future of late night in many ways the
era of late night television is gone
that's why I think whoever takes over
The Daily Show is going to need to
transition that show into a streaming
audience Noah's exit is one of many
high-profile changes hitting late night
in recent months including the
cancellation of full frontal with
Samantha B and the departures of 30-year
veteran Conan O'Brien and relative
newcomer James Corden who will step away
from late night next year from the
bottom of my heart uh can I beat a new
host
as the search for a potential Daily Show
successor begins Comedy Central has
announced a roster of guest hosts for
next year including well-known names
like Al Franken Chelsea Handler and show
alumnus Hassan Minaj thank you so much
for coming out while Trevor Noah hits
the road once again this has been an
honor thank you
for CBS mornings I'm Michelle Miller
wow wow well they have some good choices
I did reach out to Trevor yesterday or
last night to say will you come on our
show he said I'm already on a plane yeah
I am free we wish him luck and wherever
he's going in his next chapter I think
it's great as we know making TV is hard
yeah and it's even harder every day to
walk away so hey Trevor no well done
yeah sure